one of the reasons why we tend not to
make friends as often as we might comes
down to a powerful background idea whose
full destructive force we may not even
be aware of the belief that any decent
person already has all the friends they
need somewhere in our minds the notion
has been lodged that only very sad and
inept people would at this stage in
their lives still have a space in their
social agenda for a new entrant almost
everyone else anyone worth knowing
talented interesting or good would long
ago have acquired the gang to which they
are now continually and irredeemably
wedded what this punishing idea misses
is the extent to which a feeling of
loneliness and disenchantment is in
reality an ongoing and Universal
possibility in no way limited to those
of reduced appeal right now the
enchanting actor is despite the crowds
perhaps lonely as is the fated concert
pianist the renowned biologist the
skilled airline pilot the miraculous
neurosurgeon and that rather Nic looking
person you've just spotted in the corner
of the room laughing animatedly with a
group of fashionable companions it's
open to anyone of sensitivity and charm
to fail to find the right sort of allies
to have outgrown their friends from
school or university to not have landed
on congenial Spirits at work or in the
Sports Center
and therefore to be spending a lot of
their evenings on their own and we can
know this for certain of other people
because we know it first and foremost
from a very reliable source ourselves we
need to battle the Modest part of our
minds that reads our isolation as a
selective punishment and Vanquish it
with a crucial bit of evidence available
directly from our own experience other
people who know us at a social level
almost certainly find it hard to imagine
the degree to which we are exposed to
loneliness and how much we would still
like to locate a wise tender funny and
interesting new friend we have built a
predominantly cold and guarded Society
by imagining a thesis which we
implicitly know to be untrue on the
basis of our
experience the next time we spot an
interesting person we should stop
contravening the moral of our own lives
we don't have exactly the right people
in our Social Circle and nor most
probably do they so we can afford to
shed our false background ideas of
social life and go up and say hello